all right guys it's time to reveal the
theory of the day are you ready okay
okay here I go the theory of the day is
Sesame Street my friend toothbrokie here
say hi toothpicky
toothpicky says that the theory of the
day is that Sesame Street has a dark
secret and that it all begins with Elmo
wanting to bump off his friend's pet
rock but but I wanted to but that really
the root of the problem is more
systematic toothpicky says that in the
end what Rocco represents is older
Generations failing to establish proper
social norms and a troubling tendency of
defaulting to victim blaming oh wow that
was very insightful he said all that yup
now I'm curious what else does
toothpicky have to say that I deserve a
raise your two thick friend is stupid
Dan
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that'll always let you have the
last oatmeal raisin cookie you know
what's Wild my parents grew up with
Sesame Street and then I grew up with
Sesame Street and now my son Oliver can
also grow up with Sesame Street after
his paw patrol phase of course this show
started all the way back in
1969. it has run for an insane 52
Seasons a total of 4
626 episodes so far considering that the
theorist channels are at 931 episodes
I'd say we're doing a pretty good job of
catching up anyway with this show being
such a prominent ingredient in the
cultural stew and producing such a huge
volume of content you can bet that
there's going to be plenty of unusual
things that have happened inside the old
neighborhood like the time the musician
Smokey Robinson got groped by the letter
U or the time they decided to dunk on
Fox News this show is way too clean that
is it I am changing the channel from now
on I am watching Fox News now there's a
trashy news show or that time they turn
famous actor Robert De Niro into a
cabbage hey look at me I'm a cabbage
good source of riboflavin but none of
that quite compares to what surfaced
earlier this year when Twitter user at
one booty tweeted a clip where Elmo
flips out over his friend Zoe's pet rock
Rocco no no no wait wait
I'm oatmeal raisin
but Zoey watching as the usually kind
and patient Elmo loses his cookies
literally and figuratively over a rock
made this clip go absolutely viral
totaling over 9 million views with just
about every major news publication from
Vanity Fair to polygon to NPR covering
Elmo's explosive rage Elmo's Twitter
account got involved Dwayne The Rock
Johnson responded heck Sesame Street's
Tick Tock is still leaning in everyone
has had themselves a good old time and
enjoyed their thousands of dollars in
free advertising off this one clip but
then of course the internet decided to
do what it does best it dug deeper
several cyber sleuths or I suppose they
could be Sesame Street super fans found
that this wasn't the only time where
Elmo became just a wee bit upset by
Rocco shenanigans
is that was a great workout it sure was
Rocco
says hello Emma didn't hear anything it
would seem like everyone's favorite
little red monster actually has himself
a short fuse when it comes to this
particular Rock and this caught my
attention because well first off it's
just funny but also because it seems so
out of character for both the show and
Elmo Elmo is always portrayed as this
incredibly kind character and yet for
some reason he has one trigger and it's
Rocco he goes completely masked off and
devolves into a fiery red ball of rage
but why what is actually going on here
what's the backstory is there a
backstory why is Elmo suddenly
transforming from a cute cuddly
metaphorical monster into a literal one
or the memes finally coming true has
Elmo finally had enough and is ready to
watch it all burn well I looked into it
loyal theorists and the truth is
actually much sadder than all of that
Elmo is far from the monster in these
situations there's a dark past hidden
inside the history of Sesame Street's
imaginary friends and Elmo is the
helpless victim that's currently getting
steamrolled in the process let's start
off with a bit of backstory here Elmo's
beef with Rocco actually goes back much
further than you might initially expect
the earliest clip that surfaced after
the initial viral tweet came all the way
from 1999 when Zoe interrupts Elmo so
that Rocco can be the one to say the
number of the day
not Rocco now three-year-old Zoe having
an imaginary pet rock isn't in and of
itself strange these characters are
children after all it's all typical
behavior from a child with a growing
imagination and it's not like Elmo
doesn't understand imaginary friends or
pretend play either in another episode
with Rocco Elmo has a stuffed toy that
he's named baby David the two of them
pretend to be astronauts
hi baby David I'm playing with Rocco
hello
could you please watch Rocco for a
minute and what you watch him Rocco's
just a rock oh rocks need watching two
Elmo Elmo obviously doesn't think that
they're literally floating around in
space they're just playing astronauts so
clearly he can separate fantasy from
reality so then why does he have all
this animosity towards a rock imaginary
friend because here's the thing after
digging into the relationship between
these two this rivalry happens a lot in
episode 4064 Elmo Zoe and an elephant
are tasked with doing the Rocco dance
that's Mr Rocco and Elmo doesn't
understand why other characters insist
that Rocco is such a good dancer
oh but what a dancer such Grace in
episode 4424 Zoe insists that Rocco is
getting married and she throws a huge
event complete with guests and a cake
much to the confusion and frustration of
Elmo Rocco has to choose a best man see
best man for a rock this is the silliest
thing this pattern holds even going as
far back as Rocco's first appearance in
episode
3809 where Elmo straight up laughs in
Zoe's face when she tries to introduce
him Elmo is right here see he's my new
best friend Rocco but Zoey it's a rock
laughing in your friend's face when she
introduces you to her new friend
imaginary or otherwise not exactly a
very kind thing to do there Elmo seems
remarkably out of character for this
gentle and sweet monster but why what is
the actual backstory here well from the
Creator's standpoint this was always
what they intended reading interviews
with the writers that came out after the
viral video they intended for Elmo to
always get frustrated by the whole Rocco
situation see while the clips of Elmo
getting frustrated are hilarious and
show him being an absolute Savage to
this rock the full episodes actually
paint a much different picture yeah in
the episodes Elmo always starts stubborn
and insists that Rocco is just rock but
in basically every single situation he
either exhibits an enormous amount of
patience or goes out of his way to
befriend Rocco for Zoe's sake for
instance that episode where Rocco is
getting married Elmo is honored when
Rocco actually wants him to become the
best man in another episode number 4077
while the group is having fun on a play
date and they're swinging on a tire
swing Zoe insists that Rocco get a turn
before Elmo despite him not wanting
Rocco to get a turn because you know
it's Rock Elmo eventually relents and
patiently Waits his turn while Rocco
goes first and during the elephant dance
session that I mentioned earlier Elmo
keeps dancing for Rocco despite being
knocked around by the giant elephant in
Rocco's constant criticism of Elmo's
moves the elephant was great but Elmo
shooby dooby doos need work so while
Elmo does tend to lose his cool whenever
Rocco gets brought into the picture by
the end of the episode he generally
learns and grows from the experience but
hold on go go back to that last example
Elmo is being physically and
psychologically attacked here he's being
knocked around by an elephant and made
fun of for his dance moves all of it for
the benefit of Rocco in the cookie clip
Elmo's favorite cookie is being given
away to an inanimate object and on the
tire swing Elmo winds up having to share
his turn because Rocco has gone before
him and suddenly the adult Gabby is a
run out of time who's next
who's in line ahead of you it's his turn
you know Elmo Croco is next in line
in each of these situations and others
that I'm not talking about Zoe is always
the one pulling some kind of cruel stunt
on Elmo enough so that I have to ask is
she the true monster here it'd be one
thing if Zoe actually thought that Rocco
was alive but she doesn't she
understands what he is in that Infamous
cookie clip Zoe admits that Rocco isn't
actually alive he doesn't eat or breathe
or grow it's true that Rocco really
really isn't alive like you and I are he
doesn't eat or breathe or grow right
well yeah in fact the episode that
introduces Rocco also features a song
that specifically says that rocks aren't
alive and cannot eat
candy like your mother seems like a very
clear message from the creators of the
show so Zoe understands that Rocco isn't
alive he isn't really saying all these
things to Elmo or wanting to eat his
favorite type of cookie so that would
imply then that Zoe has to be the one
being the real jerk here right I mean if
you go back and watch these interactions
with that fact in mind find the tone
drastically shifts all of a sudden this
isn't a case of a girl wanting her
imaginary friend to have the oatmeal
raisin cookie that he prefers it's
depriving Elmo of the cookie that he
wants that sequence with the dancing
elephant it's not a girl passing along
constructive criticism from her
imaginary friend it's just her having an
excuse to say mean things to Elmo the
incident with the swing that we
mentioned earlier it's not a girl
wanting to make sure that her imaginary
friend gets his turn to the fun it's
about making Elmo wait before he can
have fun it's about control Zoe uses
Rocco as a means of controlling all of
those around her in fact after Rocco
gets to swing Zoe then insists that
Rocco keep swinging further delaying
Elmo's turn
[Music]
oh what's that Rocco says he's having
such a good time he wants to swimming
not to mention that this entire
situation starts because Zoe interrupts
Elmo's playdate with Gabby and forces
Rocco into it somebody
who
LLY rocks can't play and once he's in
rocco once again steamrolls Elmo's plan
so what are we gonna do let's say the
alphabet wait a minute what's that Rocco
he says he'd rather jump
can't jump
but that wouldn't be fair to Rocco Zoe
was the one who wanted to jump here
Rocco was just the excuse at another
point in episode 4258 despite his
protests she asks Elmo to hold Rocco's
hand only to come back and claim that
he's holding something else it's not
Rocco's hand that's his butt
watch it there Zoe that is a serious
accusation you're making you're fixing
to get Elmo canceled but in all
seriousness this is yet another example
of her using Rocco to humiliate Elmo
despite him ultimately doing what she
wants I could go on and on here listing
more and more examples but the long and
short of it is that Zoe's actions are
just cruel she's using Rocco as an
excuse not just to get what she wants
but then to terrorize Elmo while getting
what she wants time and time again so
there we have it right despite what
we've seen these viral Clips Zoe is
actually the evil monster lurking on
Sesame Street tormenting and gaslighting
Elmo in an unchecked reign of terror
right well not exactly you see while Zoe
isn't exactly treating Elmo the best
here you have to remember like Elmo
she's three years old despite being
three years old for the past 50 years
either way Zoe is a child and just like
we can't blame Elmo for his negative
response to Rocco it's not exactly fair
to pin all this blame for the toxic
relationship between the two on her
behavior especially when children at
that age can't really understand complex
topics like morality outside of just
this is right this is wrong no the root
problem here actually goes much deeper
in Sesame Street all the way down to the
people that are supposed to be looking
after these adorable little monsters see
when it comes to this Rocco situation
it's the adults on Sesame Street both
the humans and the Monsters who aren't
doing what needs to be done for the best
interests of either Elmo or Zoe in every
single situation that I've brought up
here today the adults are bending over
backwards to make sure that Zoe is Happy
Walking the Tightrope to indulge her
fantasies about Rocco despite knowing
that he's just a rock now let me be
clear being a parent engaging with a
child's imaginary friend great thing to
do totally fine it is healthy to engage
with the child's fantasies to a certain
degree respecting their imagination but
the adults on Sesame Street are actually
taking this to a whole nother level a
dangerous level and it's doing more harm
than good psychologist Dr Samantha
Rodham Whitten explains that while
fostering a child's imagination is great
parenting imaginary friends can get out
of hand in certain situations you cannot
let the imaginary friend turn into a way
for the child to control the family
because that teaches the kids the wrong
lesson again think of the very first
clip that brought this whole situation
to light Rocco was not only given a
cookie but at first was given Elmo's
favorite cookie over Elmo and instead of
really getting down on one knee and
being firm with Zoe about being fair to
Elmo the adult in the clip just kinda
lets it happen
instead please damn well that was my
last one back when Zoe interrupts Elmo's
play date the adult should have stepped
in to defend Elmo who was clearly
uncomfortable saying no to Zoe
oh Rocco and when Zoe and Elmo get into
a shouting match because Rocco wants to
jump instead of Elmo's choice of saying
the alphabet the adult should have been
the one to Defuse The Situation instead
they come up with this
maybe we can jump and say the alphabet
at the same time
[Music]
each time Elmo's wants and needs are
ignored by the people around him in
order to appease a rock the same thing
happens with the swing later sure the
adult checks in to see whether Elmo's
okay with Rocco going first are you sure
you're okay with this Elmo yeah almost
next anyway but when she suddenly has to
go and Elmo doesn't get a full turn to
himself almost patience isn't rewarded
he's the one left holding the bag and
these aren't the only examples of adult
characters letting Zoe through the form
of Rocco walk all over Elmo and that
dancing clip that we showed you earlier
the elephant calls Rocco your greatness
and Sir even forcing Elmo to make sure
that he calls him Mr Rocco
should switch places if it's okay with
knockout that's Mr Rocco the full
wedding that's thrown for Rocco and his
bride Petra really takes it as far as it
can go an expensive wedding cake is
ordered and people dress up they stress
over being late for this rock these
adults are enabling Zoe letting her
control so much of their lives and
Sesame Street in an unhealthy way and
worse they're letting her stress Elmo
out drive him insane exasperate him to
this Breaking Point remember he's three
he doesn't have the tools to understand
why they're treating this rock in this
way a way that is mind you better than
the way that they're treating him but
why why are these parents seemingly so
scared to really put their foot down
when it comes to Rocco well it's sad to
say but this actually has its roots and
entirely good intentions and we can
trace the reason why all the way back to
the 1970s and a little character named
Mr Snuffleupagus yep I'm serious this
conspiracy goes deep see Rocco isn't the
first time that Sesame Street has
addressed the idea of imaginary friends
with an ongoing storyline let's just say
that the way they did it before was
problematic back in 1971 since Sesame
Street introduced Aloysius Snuffleupagus
a big hairy elephant-like monster who
befriends Big Bird it's cool another new
character for all the others on the show
to interact with right except there was
a problem Big Bird was the only person
who ever saw Mr Snuffleupagus and
whenever Big Bird tried to introduce him
to any of the human characters Mr
Snuffleupagus would be gone disappeared
Into Thin Air or lumbering off screen
just in time to miss everyone what a day
I finally get to meet all of Birds
friends let's go get our stuff and we'll
meet back here
they were just here
oh they're all back I've got to tell
bird I just saw everybody here I saw
them all it got to the point that while
the human characters would play along
with big bird they didn't believe him
when he said that Mr Snuffleupagus was a
real thing and my Nest there's Mr
snuffalapagos he is now yes now I'm not
gonna waste my time I'm gonna go see
some imaginary animal I want to get this
finished I want to go rest but I want to
go meet Mrs Snuffleupagus the wood can
wait so much so that it became a
recurring joke that would run for 14
years and then things changed in the
mid-1980s Sesame Street's creators saw
an episode of 60 Minutes highlighting
the statistics involving child abuse and
neglected home the people working on
Sesame Street felt that having their
adult characters refused to believe a
six-year-old Big Bird when he's trying
to tell him something could make the
children watching at home think that no
adults would believe them if they came
forward about something serious and so
finally they decided to introduce Mr
snuffleup yes to the rest of the cast in
November of 1985 Big Bird was finally
Vindicated as the adults came face to
face with Snuffy and their jaws hit the
floor I told you there was a
Snuffleupagus and last you've seen him
and you gotta believe it right he's not
imaginary but you never believed me
enter Rocco I suspect that in the
aftermath of the Mr Snuffleupagus drama
the creators of Sesame Street leaned
hard too hard in the other direction now
the lesson they seem to be passing along
isn't just that grown-ups believe you
when you tell them things but they'll go
along with it so much that you can then
use your imaginary friends to torture
other kids to control everyone around
you and none of this actually speaks to
Elmo's State of Mind sure it's important
to make sure that Zoe feels believed and
validated but what about Elmo pointing
out that Rocco is just a rock why aren't
his accurate observations and ensuing
confusion getting equally acknowledged
instead there's nothing in yet another
episode Zoe ignores Elmo's protests over
not wanting to watch Rocco could you
please watch Rocco for a minute Emma to
watch him Rocco's just a rock rocks need
watching too Elmo I'll be back in a
minute but when Rocco suddenly
disappears guess who's the one left
having to apologize Elmo you didn't
watch Rocco for me and now he's gone
it wasn't his fault he never said he
would watch Rocco it was never his
responsibility
be gone Elmo I I asked you to watch him
yeah you did but you never got an
affirmative answer there Zoe where is
Elmo's right to autonomy in this
situation nowhere it has no place right
now on Sesame Street in every Rocco
scene on the show that I watched Elmo is
consistently left last on the tire swing
he's the one forced by everyone around
him to give up his cookie to appease a
rock Elmo is silenced so is it any
wonder that he'd hate this thing after
so many years but hey that's just a
theory a film Theory and cuts
foreign
[Music]
[Music]